OK, some interesting. So I actually am glad
to see on the David Pakman show sub Reddit
this morning, which is of course David Pakman
dot com slash r e d DHT. A post asking is
Trump making a comeback linking to a bunch
of different polling data, which seems to
suggest that the huge lead that Biden maybe
had about a month ago may be narrowing now.
I am going to make the case in the next segment
that there is no such lead. It's not a question
of it's narrowing. It's. It does not exist.
And I will make the mathematical case. I will
make a qualitative case for you as well. And
I'm really glad that people on the sub Reddit
are discussing that now.
Also, I don't want to spend a lot of time
on this, but there have been allegations made
that I eat mac and cheese with a spoon, which
is really weird.
Like if you need a spoon for mac and cheese,
it's really like a pasta soup. I use spoons
only for desserts and soups, not for pasta.
And I guess that in some circles this is considered
controversial. But yes, I do eat mac and cheese
with a fork. I think that that's the correct
utensil. This is not really important given
everything that we have going on. But somehow
this triggered a lot of people in my audience
and I really don't know why. So if that's
something you want to weigh in on, the place
to do it would be the David Pakman show. Subrata
David Pakman dot com slash r e d d i t.
But the focus here really important to get
back to the material, important, materially
important things. I don't know when people
talk about is Trump making a comeback? I don't
know that Donald Trump needs to make a comeback.
And that's what I want to really focus in
on next.